Speaker 1: Rhonda, sanctimonious is now using
me. David Pacman, in one of his newest campaign
ads. This was published over the 4th of July
holiday. This is an ad that not only includes me,
but it includes our friend Farron Cousins from
Ring of Fire and many others. The point that
the ad tries to make is that we on the left were
all scared of Ron DeSantis. What we're actually
saying in the clips that are used is that we
think DeSantis is more dangerous than Trump
to some degree because he's less incompetent.
And that's true. It's actually not a terrible
ad. The context is we all think DeSantis is
nuts. Take a listen to this and you will see
me pop up a number of times.
Speaker 4: If Trump was
the original Terminator, DeSantis.
Speaker 5: Is like the t-1000. Ron DeSantis
is far more dangerous than Donald.
Speaker 2: Trump, a.
Speaker 3: More disciplined extremist.
Speaker 5: They're just like, Oh, well,
at least a scientist isn't crazy like Trump.
I'm like, No, you should be more scared of him
than Trump. He's more savvy, he's more coy, and he
doesn't have the pitfalls that Donald Trump does.
Speaker 4: The real reason this man is
so terrifying. Is because he's managed
to succeed in areas where Trump has failed.
Speaker 5: If anyone out there thinks that
somehow he is any better than Donald Trump
and they got real Ron DeSantis. If you thought
Donald Trump was bad, you got another thing.
Speaker 1: He may actually be able to do a
lot of the things Trump merely
wanted to do but failed to do.
Speaker 5: The census actually knows
the system, and I think Ron DeSantis
is far more dangerous than Donald Trump,
But he's also more competent, I think.
Speaker 2: Than Trump, because
he's not so incompetent.
Speaker 5: He's more cunning.
Speaker 2: He's not an incompetent
administrator in the way that Trump was.
Speaker 5: He would be more able to get
things done. Ron DeSantis is far more dangerous
than Donald Trump. Far more dangerous than Donald.
Speaker 1: Trump, far more likely if he becomes
president to successfully implement a lot of these
horrible and disastrous ideas. Now, you'll notice
that when I mention horrible and disastrous ideas,
they put the word awesome on the screen with a
little asterisk. So, you know, I saw a comment
about this ad that it's very creepy that they're
proud of this to a reasonable person, like if you
just put aside party affiliation. DeSantis seems
like he's running for dictator. I read a number of
comments like this in response to my tweet about
this video. But these are such weird times that
because the highest virtue is triggering the left
and triggering the libs. They actually get mileage
from so many people saying this guy is dangerous
for his authoritarian ideas. I saw another comment
that said this ad would be more effective if
they left out the parts where we're all calling
DeSantis dangerous like that. They could have
gotten rid of all of those things and the ad
would actually be stronger. But it's almost like a
badge of honor that much of the country, including
folks like me, see DeSantis as incredibly
dangerous. So another response to this ad,
which was along the lines of trying to pander to
the right by bragging about how much of a fascist
you want to be is a pretty bad strategy if you
make it to the general election. And there's
actually a lot of insight there. As I've said
before, the way DeSantis is running this campaign
is maybe useful in a Republican primary, and maybe
not because he's making no progress whatsoever
against Trump. Still polling low twenties, but the
anti-woke stuff, the I'm a wannabe dictator stuff,
the left thinks I'm dangerous stuff. It might play
well in a Republican primary and it might not,
but I don't see any way that this is useful
to DeSantis in a general election. Now,
a couple of people wrote to me and said, David,
you should sue him for using you in the video. I
have not consulted with an intellectual property
attorney on this. It seems pretty clear to me that
if you are a candidate for office and there are
people publicly commenting about your candidacy
for office, that all of that stuff is fair, use
that. That's my instinct. I have no interest in
suing. I'm more interested in the fact that
he's now using me in a campaign ad. Let me
know your thoughts. Make sure you subscribe to
the YouTube channel. As we press forward towards
2 million YouTube subscribers. I believe we
should save the recording of today's show
because it's actually a pretty good
show. I hope you'll stay with me.